Speaker 1: This is really just getting sad.
I have video for you today of an extremely
disheveled sounding Mypillow Mike Lindell
claiming that every Utah vote is fake in his
latest febrile tirade about machines and elections
and all these different things, we're.
Speaker 3: Doing a class action lawsuit against
all machines.
Speaker 1: Okay, so here is pillow saying
nobody's really voting in Utah.
It is all completely fabricated.
Speaker 3: I mean, you know, I believe you
are the CCP, the globalist, the union party.
I believe it's all one just happy family.
And and and we showed it on all the 50 states.
You get to Utah where there's no one Friday
day election, it's all mail in as pure crime.
Nobody votes in Utah.
Nobody.
Brannon It's all just made up.
Speaker 1: So Utah is a state of about 3 million
people, 3.1 million people, roughly, live
in Utah.
And some of them are adults and some of them
are registered to vote and some of them actually
do vote.
And the idea that just it's all made up because
it's mail-in is completely and totally absurd.
Now I'm actually willing to go further.
It's not just that no one votes in Utah.
I don't even know that Utah is real.
I haven't been there.
I've never met anyone from Utah.
I know Mitt Romney exists, but do we really
know that when he left Massachusetts after
being governor, he really went to this place
called Utah?
We really don't.
Now, of course, I'm kidding.
But in all seriousness, we have a country
where I don't know that I would say half,
but a whole bunch of people watch people like
Pillow for entertainment purposes only.
Right.
We know he's nuts or very confused or some
combination of the two or not with it.
And we see it as a complete and total joke
and we watch to ask and to see answered.
How far are others willing to go in believing
that anything this guy says is based in reality?
Right.
So we exist.
These people are so susceptible to being propagandized
that it's just funny to see the other half
of the country.
And again, it's not really half.
A lot of people just don't pay attention.
They have no clue who pillow is.
But you've got another portion that is so
susceptible to being tricked and scammed and
propagandized by people like Mike Pillow,
Alex Jones, all of these different people.
Speaker 3: Thank your lucky stars every day.
You're not David.
Speaker 1: Pakman.
I know, I know.
And it's really an incredible contrast and
it doesn't have to be that way.
I promise you, we get emails from all over
the world and you know, I've been to so many
different places and engaged with the political
people, with political activists and systems.
In a lot of countries, people disagree about
policy, but you don't have a large portion
of the population to be susceptible to clowns
like this guy.
You just don't.
Nobody falls for it.
Tiny, tiny portions of the population fall
for it, and the vast majority of the political
discourse is sane.
Here's one other clip from the pillow stuff
Mike Lindell is reacting to.
It sort of seems like he's lost Steve Bannon.
It seems like Steve Bannon is not falling
for all of the machine stuff.
But pillow says, no, no, no, he's secretly
still believes all of it.
Speaker 3: Everybody knows Steve Bannon.
And he always says on his show, I'm not a
machine guy.
Now, you know, he said that to me yesterday.
He said that to me yesterday in the booth.
I'm not really a machine guy.
All right.
So then we get.
Yeah, he says.
And I think so.
You know, deep down, of course, he's of course
she believes the machine's got to go.
Of course he doesn't.
He's afraid of Dominion or Smartmatic, right?
Leave at the end of the night, everybody.
I said so.
Steve, are you a machine guy?
No, he goes, I'm a machine guy.
Yeah.
We're doing a class action lawsuit against
all machines.
Speaker 1: Yeah, my espresso machine is currently
being deposed.
It's crazy.
This reminds me a little bit of the Jordan
Peterson clip.
We looked at this clip in detail because it's
so fascinating where Jordan Peterson said
there aren't really atheists.
There are people who claim to be atheists,
but deep down, they really aren't.
And of course, that type of statement is completely
falsifiable.
If even what people claim to be isn't really
what they are, then you can't really actually
talk about things like atheism.
There's no atheists, because even the group
that describes themselves that way, they're
actually religious deep down.
Really?
Which religion?
I don't know.
Christianity, I sort of guess this stuff is
absolutely hilarious.
And there he has a following.
And that's maybe the scariest thing about
the United States